and i love this guy um celebrated my
50th birthday with him in new york
susie surprised me with josh charles
showing up and just so much fun
i love this guy voice of america's game
in uh he loves football
i don't know anybody loves football more
than him and certainly loves the
baltimore ravens more than him with a
big game coming up my buddy josh charles
back on the show how are you josh
how you doing rich so i've been going
back and forth
uh telling the guys here do i call you
confident but nervous
or nervous yet confident how do i
describe you
today josh yeah it's a tricky one
because i really
i really don't know i mean i feel i feel
relatively confident but i i
i honestly i could see it going either
way you know i mean i think it's going
to come down to who makes
makes a couple of those plays that that
turn the difference
uh in the game and we'll see i mean i
think a big
big question mark obviously there's been
some talk about the weather it doesn't
seem like the weather's going to be too
too bad even if it is a little wet or it
snows it's not going to accumulate
that's what i've heard
so it's really about you know
i think if the ravens can can can run
the ball
and that is one could say in a very
balanced team like bills and a very good
team but i respect
a lot i really like the bills so it's
hard you know because when you when you
get in these playoff games you like to
sort of
you know like the titans i got to hate
on a little bit because
there was some of the bad blood and
butler and this is like i don't i don't
hate anybody from the bills i like the
bills i like their fan base i'm happy
for them they're a good team josh
allen's great what he's done this year
it's great to see diggs maryland guy you
know stepping up
um but i really think if we can run the
ball consistently which is our bread and
butter um
keep them off the field and then it's
going to come down to a question of you
know what wink has in store in terms of
pressures and fake pressures and
what we're going to look at it's going
to be a fun game to watch i i really i
do feel confident i don't feel as
confident as i felt in the titan game
just because i think the builds are a
more balanced team
but i like the ravens i like the ravens
in it i like them
so you know i the the offense for the
ravens when it cooks
is when you have no earthly idea
that who's got the ball coming out of
the backfield you know you don't know
who
you don't know if lamar is a passer or a
runner you don't know if the runner is a
runner
a blocker or a receiver and you also
don't know
if the fullback is the receiver you
don't know if the running back
is the blocker and the full black
fullback is a receiver it is just
truly amazing but it does predicate
on on being able to run that offense and
not
have to come back from so many points
down and that's my concern
again yeah unless unless was that
rectified is it hollywood brown is it
dez i don't know you know what i mean
like is has that well i
mean i haven't rectified we don't really
know and you're right i mean that is i
mean look
to see lamar you know and i know you
feel the same way because i know you've
been a big supporter of his but you know
the criticism and some of it you know is
fair i mean you know
he's a young quarterback you know he's
he he's
still learning and making adjustments um
but the idea that he was such a victim
of his own success you know
can't win the big game i mean he wants
he's won some big games in the regular
season by the way but
oh and two in the playoffs up until last
week so to get that monkey off his back
and at the same time
come back from 10 points and really just
sort of put the team on his shoulders
but i think you know look none of those
other quarterbacks that were drafted
ahead of him in that year have been to
the playoffs you know this is the first
year
so to criticize him for something where
he's actually made the playoffs two
years and as a ravens fan certainly i'm
frustrated by
you know both of those losses
particularly last year where i really
did think we
we had the chance to to do it all the
way but i think you're right i mean i
think
that's that's the question i mean and
also on on the defensive side of the
ball i think
as a ravens fan i think we were all kind
of
you know waiting for that type of
defensive performance you know and to
see
them gel at that right time it's the
first time coleas
uh big baby brandon williams and derek
wolf
you know had really been on the field
together for you know in a while because
due to certain injuries mixed with the
covet epidemic
uh an outbreak on the team so to see
those guys
and really have such a dominant
performance are they capable of doing
that against the bills that's a more
balanced attack yes they don't have the
rushing game that that the titans do
but they're more balanced and and josh
can beat you with his feet a little bit
as well
i i don't know you know i mean that's
what i'm excited to see i mean but the
question is if they if they turn in an
80
effort of that one against the titans is
that going to be enough you know
depending on how we do on offense so
i think the amazing thing that you said
you know about that you just don't know
what what always impresses me is when i
watch
i mean i'm obsessed with baldinger right
i mean i just his
breakdowns to me are just like the
greatest thing on the planet i mean
they're the great
i look they're like christmas for me you
know every week i just i
i look at him i want to watch him i feel
like he makes like a dummy like me
understand the game better
and when he breaks down you know he
breaks down those point of attacks and
he freezes the play for a second
and you can see like in that tennessee
game exactly what you're talking about
and it's not the first time you know
clearly it happens all the time where
the linebackers are frozen
just that split second and with the
speed that we have between dobbins and
gus
and lamar you see what the challenge is
facing this team
i thought the titans did a pretty good
job for a while but what i
was impressed with was roman you know
just stuck to the plan
and you know that paid off and we'll see
we'll see what what what they have in
store i'm sure
there'll be some wrinkles and he'll
throw some things out there it was nice
to see hollywood
you know move from uh you know beverly
hills adjacent into his nickname a
little bit more appropriate
um because there's been some times where
you know his mouth has been
you know a little bit bigger than the
game but i i do feel like he really
stepped up in a big way and we need him
you know
we need him and and he played fantastic
and made some great catches lamar made
that great over the shoulder throw
so you know as far as i'm concerned if
he has another game like that he's
beverly hills brown
yeah it's about to say that that that uh
i guess hollywood brown is much better
than thousand oaks brown or tarzana
brown or
you know rancho cucamonga brown or i'm
just i'm just trying to go through
the names i hear on traffic and weather
together but i'm gonna give him luckily
he's gonna get he's gonna get like homey
hills brown pretty soon
that is a high rent district josh
charles uh my buddy and die hard ravens
and die hard football fan here on the
show and
we can sit here and go x's and o's as
much as possible and we're showing a
photograph of you from last year's nfl
honors
uh with lamar the night that he was
crowned uh
the mvp and the x's and o's we can we
can sit here about wrinkle this wrinkle
that but he's like a human wrinkle like
he is
the the game changed on a third down in
a game
where points were a premium and then
boom touchdown
from midfield like what in the world is
that like to be a fan of a quarterback
like that
i mean i'd love to know just walk me
through what that's like what that
sensation is like no says the jets
correct correct josh you know me so what
what is that what is that like what is
that like joe well i'll tell you what
it's like i mean
after years of stony case scott mitchell
and elvis go back and you know i mean
you name
all the guys i mean listen i was a huge
i'm and still am a huge joe fan
you know arguably that postseason one of
the greatest runs of all time and and
the guy's just a class act and has
such a pretty deep ball but offensively
to see what we're doing i think ravens
like we got we've gotten a little
spoiled you know we were
so hungry to have that kind of
creativity to have that player on the
field
and that's what my dad was saying the
other night we were talking he's like
he's just
he's a game changer i mean you just all
it takes is like you said that one third
and nine
48 and next thing you know the game's
tied and
the momentum just shifted and i don't
think we ever let up on it after that so
i think this is going to be a harder
challenge i mean i think the bills you
know
rightfully so have earned their seed and
and like i said like
i will be disappointed if we don't pull
it off but i'll i'm i'm
also like a fan of that team so it it's
really hard
but i i i do think the ravens are in a
good mojo right now and
obviously turnovers will be huge you
know what i mean i mean we didn't
we had that one early in the game but
that was it and i don't i don't think we
can do that in this game
i think everybody's got to protect the
ball and we do have to run it
consistently
and and stay at it and if we get behind
that will be tough and we'll be
challenged so
we'll see i mean i'm excited about it i
can't wait i just wish it wasn't so late
so my son could watch it because he's
pissed off at me
how old is ronco now josh how old is he
now he's he just turned six
in december okay and he's just getting
there he's he's really
he's really into the ravens but the
thing about talking football with a
six-year-old and maybe there's different
six-year-olds that
know all he he's pretty pretty
knowledgeable like he will go through
and he'll name all the teams
but my favorite thing talking to him
about it is he's always like he's like
who's playing and when i tell him who's
playing like he knows who's good he
knows who's back
he's always like oh they're going to
crush him they're going to crush him so
i try to explain to him
hey just because the team's favorite or
just because they're the better team
it doesn't always mean they're going to
win right that's why they gotta play the
game sometimes the team is not as good
wins um on paper and uh and so
i don't know that he fully gets that yet
but he's always oh that got crushed
so we'll see he's excited and uh i think
all ravens and fans are excited
and i also think this suits this team
better in a weird way like last year i
mean we weren't used to that we're used
to sort of
you know being the being on the outside
looking in you know being the wild card
being on the road i think it just suits
the mentality of that team better
sitting having a cushy bye week
you know thinking we're just gonna keep
rolling uh
this is this keeps him hungry and i'm
i'm expecting it to be a fantastic
fantastic football game well i guess in
the fact that it's unfortunate that the
game starts too late for rocco now it
was a benefit to you
i imagine on that monday night that you
have to tell your six-year-old why
why daddy and the rest of the country
didn't really believe lamar was out with
an iv
right josh on that monday night
that'd be tough i had the same feelings
but like i told you
you know i've talked to people that know
you know and
and they tell me without question that
you're telling the truth that
he was cramping up you know um and
that's another way to put it i guess
what do you guys think well do you not
think
uh we think he's uh number eight in the
program but number
number two in the fourth quarter is
really what we think you know
so there's two things one is you know he
came on the show and talked about how
the defense is calling plays out uh
offensively so he is he is he he does
not have
a lion bone in his body that's number
one so we know that uh he just he speaks
the truth is what he does
but number two the the one thing that we
saw was when he was trying to enter the
locker room
waving the poor schnook who was uh
exiting at the same time he's trying to
enter we've all
seen that quick motion of the hand to
move uh
because a movement was happening that's
that's we've we've all been there
that's what i'm saying i guess here's my
here's my issue with that right
and i love that we're breaking this down
yes uh you know uh
but i do think i love that we're washing
it down
um i do think that uh if it was that
let's just say it was why why would it
have taken so long i mean you know
you've got trainers there you got people
though they'll give you the
whatever the you know imodium whatever
it is take it
and you know do your thing and do your
business and get back he was gone for
like almost
almost a quarter wasn't it like 15
minutes
that's a long explosion i'm telling you
that i think
in and again ask people point blank that
i know
that said 100 the truth dude was
cramping up bad
that's what it was we need a ball we
don't see him we need a baldy breakdown
we need a baldy breakdown on it's
basically what we need we need to
opt for it just freeze it squeeze it as
he's going in
now look at here at the point of attack
you see how he's shaking his hand a
little bit he's waddling a little bit
that little poor kid the water boy he
doesn't know what hit him he doesn't
know which way lamar's going is he going
down left is he going down
oh my god i'm knocking stuff over i'm
laughing so hard
josh charles here on the rich eisen show
hey uh before i let you go i've never
asked you about
because you know we talked pop culture
here too before i let you go we've nev
i've never really asked you about
uh dead poets society um which
celebrated a 31-year anniversary
last year and uh i've really never asked
you about your experience on the set
we're seeing you right there as knox
overstreet how old were you were you 17
shooting this movie with robert 17 yeah
yeah i mean
you know it's amazing stories that movie
was supposed to get made
a year earlier right with a different
director
not robin being in it um and
and it was set to go in like georgia or
something and me
and ethan i think we're we were two
people who were cast
and i was set to leave and fly down and
got my big break and i was really
excited and in the movie
that they they pulled it they couldn't
find a star to be in the movie that the
studio would support at the time and the
director wanted some people who at the
time were more unknown like
alec baldwin and and uh liam neeson you
know but like
the studio want a big name and the
director you know so it fell apart
and then it came back a year later and
uh when it came back a year later
i think uh peter weir was directing it
and he had seen the screen test
and i i don't think you know he thought
i was right or whatever and so i
had to go and like re-audition for the
movie and so i like i had to go
meet him in new york and read for him
again and kind of convince him
and i got the part again it was a really
you know great feeling so then
it really just felt like it was meant to
be and then making it was
was really special memories to get to
work with someone like robin williams at
the time and i remember being
really struck um by him because
you know we were all star struck by him
but he was very he was doing a play at
the time he was doing something with
stephen martin
um and so he came a little late so i
shot a lot of my stuff because it didn't
involve him earlier
and when he came he really kind of
respected his place in the movie that he
knew he was the big star but
like that we were all sort of sharing it
in this ensemble movie and he really was
was very treated us like like real
equals and he was
always funny of course but also like
really um you could tell just like he
had this beautiful sensitivity to him
you know and
and um and you know took acting
seriously
obviously and was such a major talent
and
he um you know i remember i remember
like i know he was very
and i i knew a little bit that he was
very close with like david crosby
you know and uh the musician i knew
the musician didn't get the musician the
favorite
and that you know robin obviously that
was i think reports had battled his own
sort of
you know demons in terms of abuse and
stuff like that and
um you know with his own sort of you
know excess
issues and uh and i remember i was
really into music and i was playing the
american dream record
and i had it on you know i was like walk
man this is this is stating ourselves
here
he was like what do you listen to or in
the trailer i said i'm listening to you
know american dream and
there's this beautiful song by david
carley and i didn't know he was friends
at the time with david crosby you know i
mean
like the song is beautiful and i
remember putting it on for him and he
just listened and
you know and then i found out later that
like he knew him and then i i put it all
together of like oh my god like he's had
his own
sort of struggles with addiction at
times in his life and i just remember he
was very moved by it and he just was
i don't know he was just a great great
guy such a talent i think a real
lesson to us all that um
you know the the the we project so much
on to
sort of the our movie stars and the
people we like and everybody
you know doesn't matter who you are
you're not immune to it i mean look what
just happened with congressman raskin
and his
you know beautiful son you know that
that you know
there's just demons out there and people
are fighting them and it doesn't matter
how much money or how much success you
have and sometimes that's what drives
you
but the memories from him were very you
know from that time were very pure
and um filled with with a lot of joy and
that he was such a genuinely
uh warm human being who was very funny
you know he used to like that
you know i used to do richard pryor for
him and he liked that because i was a
big richard pryor fan growing up so i
would i would
have the balls to somehow you know do an
impersonation in front of rob
williams huh that's that's unbelievable
and i i guess just as what you're saying
too josh that
the message of the film uh carpe diem
right seize the day and get on your desk
and yap
you know like that's unbelievably what
we're talking about about what
what happens when you start out young
like that it's like you know you get
that break and then
the problem is is you think you know now
i'm 49 years old right now you know i've
been in this business i've been
i was my second movie i've been acting
professionally since i'm 15.
and that was my first major role and you
working with peter weir and robin
williams and all these
other amazingly talented young actors
you know and ethan someone who
you know him and i still remain friends
and dylan custman is another one who i
consider a friend and uh and jamie
waterston
all these great people and robert shawn
leonard and always talented gail hansen
and al rogerio and just
great guys and we bonded in the radisson
and wilmington delaware and going to the
mall
playing video games and working with
peter weir who is this exceptional
extraordinary talent so
you tend to think as a kid like oh my
god they're all going to be like this
this is what the movie industry is like
and it's not it was a
was it was a special movie i think made
even more special by
by robin and his infectious spirit and
his talent and what he brought to it
and that he brought so many people into
that movie and also
by peter who was really the sort of you
know the keating of the film you know
inspiring us all playing music for us
you know when you
i would tell people if you watch that
movie you know it's uh
peter used to play music a lot it was
really and
it's something that i stayed with you
know as an actor my whole
career since ju in order to sort of get
into a moment of the scene or
the tone or the feeling of what you want
i remember when we shot the final
scene where we all stand up on our desks
he would play all these music this music
and he did he had like a
boombox you know i mean it was like
terrible and my dad because i grew up in
baltimore which wasn't very far my dad
was commercial director and had a really
cool like new
bose boom box that was like giant and
sounded great and he brought it to the
set for peter and so when we
when we filmed that scene he was playing
uh
maurice chard's uh jars music from the
mission you know that beautiful
soundtrack from the mission
and so uh no no i'm sorry
when he was playing uh i think maura
cohn did the the music for the mission
my my apologies annual more cone
soundtrack for the mission but he was
playing that while we were all
performing that
and if you listen to that soundtrack uh
it might be fun for people who are
fans of the movie to watch it and think
and then mauricio who ended up doing
the music for the poet society you know
created his own version of that
but that's a memory that i'll always
stay with just that that boombox that my
dad brought just
blaring through and we're all standing
up and just
feeling it and um he was you know he was
an incredible
uh person to work with as a young actor
and i remember
he also did something in the original
script of the film and tom shulman won
an oscar for the movie by the way it was
it was the one oscar that i think the
movie won it was nominated for a couple
but he won
but in the original screenplay um you
find out at the end of the movie that
that robin's character had
had was dying i think it was cancer i
don't remember but
but like if you think about the film now
it's like all the stuff with neil
and and and and and the climax of that
and then at the end
it's all coming down on keaton and you
find out that he
is dying and that's why he's so carpe
diem and sees the day
and don't you get it don't you see and
when peter weir came on the film
it was one of the first things he said
this is going away
right and and tom shulman will tell you
this he was you know
like he was stunned and upset
and like couldn't believe what he was
hearing and now i think he thanks his
lucky stars because it was a great
just a great sign of a director like
reading the the the tone of the film
and and and and the meaning of the film
right
and somehow if you sort of you know
explain it away
like you know the reason he is this way
is because he's dying as opposed to this
is just his spirit
and this is what he's bringing to you uh
was much more i think profound and less
sentimental
you know and and just better just um and
and uh
it's one of those things where you read
you'd never think of it any other way
and then
when it's gone you're like how was that
ever in there you know this makes so
much more sense it's made so much more
um much more nuanced and interesting so
great experience uh filming in in
saint andrews school in delaware um
and and like i said was pretty close to
my home so i could i could go home on
weekends and hang although i was so
jacked up and
excited i was usually staying in the
radisson pretending i was 27 as opposed
to 17.
i love it um i love it josh josh it's
just
i i love these stories and i'm so
appreciative of you coming on and
sharing that your passion for your craft
and your movies
and and your ravens thanks for the call
josh uh
love you man enjoy the game always good
to talk about i love you too
and um give my best to everyone i know
kurt's coming on and give him my best
i love that man he's a good dude he is
um i'll talk to you guys so are you
you've got it that's josh charles
everybody
the one and only josh charles here on
the rich eisen show
some great stories right there hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here